hello everyone i'm alana and welcome to
my channel where today i am playing
planet coaster console edition
specifically on ps5
got my jewel sense here this video is
sponsored and there will be a link in
the description below to where you can
check out the game or find out more
information if you would like um but
basically i'm just gonna be you know
causing some havoc
having a good time hopefully not killing
anyone we'll see how it goes
look at him look at his cute little
pants
you're the most stylish man i've seen in
my life this charming park
is the perfect moving ground for a
budding theme park manager
eager to learn their trade i don't know
why i've done that let's just let's go
[Music]
my oh my is that a budding theme park
proprietor
i didn't guess that he would be scottish
i will admit
welcome to planet coaster these are the
key steps to creating spectacular
killstreak parks build rides and scenery
to attract us
i'm broken this week okay we're gonna
open up
the magic are we sure this is called
magic castle
who named it who named that
that seems like a bad name wait or is
that the name of the whole theme park
maybe it is okay i'm gonna build a new
ride
let's do it delete that yeah what even
is that
who built that who built all of this
rights
the elixir that's expensive we got that
kind of money okay we do have that kind
of money
beautiful boom this better make us some
money
you guys better be willing to walk that
far when you place the entrance gate you
make sure to leave enough space so you
can build a
ride queue but what if i trolled them
what if i put it over here
what if they had to walk really
inconveniently
okay this is terrible
as i possibly can wait in line to go on
the ride
it's it actually i just made a nice
start sort of by accident if you do find
any
obstacles or obstructions in your way
you can build slopes
or stairs into your path to get over
them i'm gonna make this so ridiculous
okay okay this really brings out the
evil in me huh i don't even know i had
this in me
i don't think they could get into it
don't you just come on try come on go
for it don't you want to get in this
stuck
chaos guests think magic castle is cheap
who do you think you are evil did you
see that notification oh i think i'm
covering the money let me move my webcam
hang on let's do this
i'll move myself real quick we'll go
like right here that should be better
the people visiting this park i feel
like ten dollars for this kind of ride
is
pretty expensive but we're taking a loss
okay beautiful we did it no but i need
to adjust the price of the elixir
machine
that nobody can ride what if i make it
free
just attempt them see if they try you
know
i'm the worst uh inspect people's
thoughts
what is this is somebody writing it
this is the one that everyone's talking
about that they really want fixed
what is it it's busy
know about that how about you buddy what
are you all about
well i didn't see everyone's
i would really like to know how this
dude is doing if i'm being perfectly
honest wait wait is he an employee
don't forget to immerse your guests in
the magnificent surroundings you can
place items in the scenery browser and
improve guest happiness in your
pocketing additionally improves the
queue scenery of the ride will increase
the ride's prestige
better build your own scenery creations
piece by piece oh that's pretty neat
oh a doughnut oh can i put the doughnut
there for no reason
yeah donut park you all love pirates and
you all love donuts
but what about the pirate
pyro nuts what have i done
am i a bad person okay we want one more
it's gonna be this one i don't know
where i'm gonna put it over all these
donuts no i can actually fit it
oh that is a bit nicer it is
yeah i think we've significantly
improved the pocket today you guys
okay so that's not nearly as precise as
it could be
but you can fix that because they can't
ride it
this dude's just stuck here forever
yeah that'll help i think you're right
love that's that's a good idea
that'll fix the problem that we have
with the ride for sure what is
this yes
it's
cool and i just really feel like it's
gonna change how everyone feels
about this ride what if we make it even
harder to get into
it's uh costing a lot of money just to
make me laugh i just don't know why no
one's writing it
you know it's very confusing put these
right here
just so everyone who gets off this ride
which they're definitely doing
can go to a nice stall are you guys
happy now are you happy now did i do the
thing that you needed me to do
okay i think that's enough of the
tutorial i think we've got it i think
we've figured it out
obviously it is very handy for people
who've never played a game like planet
coaster before but i'm a pro
clearly so we're gonna jump into the
career mode okay
[Music]
beautiful what do you think of this
place
eh after all your training i'll
bet you'll have this positively pirate
packed this roller coaster looks
sick um two flat rides okay
you're saying we need more rides
i could build let's throw
one one of these
i mean that's expensive but it's pretty
cool i'm gonna throw that right there
oh that's dope i just want to put a
roller coaster in here though you know
you feel me
huh i think this one's the coolest can i
afford
any of the coasters absolutely not even
close
i do know you could build them though
maybe i could make what's the cheapest
coaster that i can make
that's just for the station this is
gonna get expensive we're gonna do our
best
i know there is a coaster building
tutorial for the record
but i'll just jump in okay yeah cool
keep going up and up and up this is a
chain lift and then it's gonna be a sick
drop
oh could i do that
that seems very cool yes
oh my gosh and then we have to go home
because we have no more money so we just
need to we got to be returning at this
point
because we are out of cash ladies and
gentlemen
that's it for all of you
you're done you got your one loop i
don't want to hear about it
do you guys remember when i was happy
with
my fake abomination of a roller coaster
look how pretty this is this is the
frontier workshop which i guess is their
alternative to basically what would be
the steam workshop
on um pc whoa
that's cool you're gonna give me some
trophies for this don't mind if i do
i will give you a like for that
there is also i realize i'm in front of
it there is
there is also a challenge mode
which has four difficulty settings um
and you basically get to
choose how much money you start with
before you get
a bunch of hurdles thrown at you
basically don't feel like i'm ready for
that
don't feel like i'm ready for that just
yet don't know that that's me sandbox is
kind of the opposite i
imagine where you just kind of start and
get thrown in
city and make whatever you want
what i know this has uh infinite funds
which
all the things we could build laddie the
parks we could make
it's kind of it is cool getting to see
all the stuff unlocked
what's the most expensive one
is it here 44
it's ridiculous and i love it
as well make me throw up um all right
you guys i feel like i've shown you most
of the stuff yeah the challenge mode i
think
i'm not ready for that yet i probably
need to continue with my career mode a
little bit
first but that is it for me today
everyone thank you guys so much for
watching as i said
you can see a link in my description to
check out more about planet coaster
console edition which i
am playing on a playstation 5.
i will see you guys next time bye